My exposure to this entire area of biology began as a medical
student in my first year at Harvard Medical School.
And George Palade's discoveries were really fresh,
and they were presented in my histology course.
And when I saw those electron micrographs of vesicles and endoplasmic reticulum and
Golgi,
and so on, I immediately started thinking,
given my background in physical sciences,
how in the world could such a vesicle form?
You know, what would make that happen?
How would it know where to fuse?
And I must say,
somehow I identified that problem as one that I wanted to solve at some point.
And I got fixated on it. And I can't really tell you why,
but I just got fixated.
I found it as fascinating then as I do now.
So what we did was we wanted to reconstitute transport from the ER to the Golgi.
So we took the cells, living,
we gave them a very short pulse label with radioactive methionine and,
you know,
tricks I had learned in Harvey Lodish's lab, then homogenized the cells
to retain them in the G protein in the endoplasmic reticulum.
And then we incubated that extract to see if the glycoprotein could be further processed
by adding certain sugar residues,
especially N-acetyl glucosamine,
which we knew from the work of Phil Robins and Stuart Kornfeld and others,
occurred in the Golgi.
So if we could see that processing in vitro,
it suggested-- it would have suggested-- that transport occur.
And indeed,
after I don't know,
a month or two, we observed that that was the case,
we could see it.
But then we had a huge background. Even without any kind of an incubation
of longer than a few seconds,
even without adding ATP or cytosol,
we still saw processing.
And what we came to realize was that we already had too much of the G protein sitting in the Golgi,
and it was getting glycosylated directly there.
So that gave me the idea of what is now known as a complementation assay,
which is pretty much the standard design for most-- in those days--
most cell-free reconstitutions of transport. And what the idea is, is you want to mix two
extracts,
one from a cell that contains the cargo protein, VSV G,
but lacks the processing enzyme. The other extract from a cell that
has the processing enzyme, but lacks the cargo protein.
And so when the two are mixed,
if the cargo protein is getting glycosylated,
it must have gone from a donor membrane in the extract
of the one cell, to the processing enzyme in the Gogli of the other cell.
And so that eliminated the background that I referred to because the extract with the
VSV G protein was incapable of processing by adding sugar.
So when we set that assay up, it actually worked.
It was in I believe 1979.
I still have the gel.
It shows a very,
very faint band of VSV G protein being processed to what's called an endo H
resistant form.
It was very,
very exciting.